if you're wondering where kevin frazier
is well he's hanging exclusively with
hollywood's golf loving gang in lake
tahoe
listen michelle golf is really secondary
out here it's all about the beautiful
scenery and big stars justin timberlake
is here so is nick jonas and i just
talked to miles teller and asked him
will there be another top gun
you get tom cruise over a billion
dollars for the first time yeah that's
definitely what my team has been you
know saying um
for these future negotiations i just
sent a message the other day for his
birthday for him to you know share top
gun with with me and a lot of these
other young actors it's just been such a
such a wild ride i can't and it's and
it's still going will there be a top gun
sequel will we see you again oh that i
mean that would be that would be great
but that's all up to to tc that's all up
to tom
and pollard by the i yeah i've been i've
been uh having some conversations about
it but you know we'll see what a man
gotta do
your first time here how does it feel
you're hitting the ball great it looked
like you were really stroking it feels
terrible
is priyanka golfer at all she's uh
picking the game up she looks great in
the golf clothes so she loves that part
i'm a circle for you posted a beautiful
picture of you and malty how's
fatherhood been for you it is certainly
life-changing she's amazing brings me a
lot of joy you're you're bouncing back
from the softball injury how are you
feeling you good everything fine
basically the ground ball hit my kneecap
and it was so painful i thought it was
broken and then about two hours later i
was like i'm fine any new music you can
tease for us yeah we're working on stuff
now um
the brothers
and it's feeling really good another
first-timer snl's colin jost you know
you have a superhero in your house did
you get tips from the superhero um just
more like outfit advice a lot of
departures from snl have you guys
started to look at new folks no one's
thinking about it at all yeah well you
miss folks like pete and you know of
course yeah yeah i mean i i hope i will
still see them by the way cosmo turns
one in august do you have a big party
plan
well the one is great because you could
just make up stuff that happened at the
party and he'll never know it didn't
happen i'll be like can you believe we
got billy eilish at your first through
third birthdays he'll never know i also
got news on why anthony anderson left
law and order i wanted to go off and you
know create more shows like blackish
create things that i have
ownership in and
do something a little bit different
elite athletes are also in the mix here
at the american century championship
presented by american century
investments i'm coming off an mvp and
now you're right here on the golf course
it's a great way to celebrate i love the
game i love to compete so what i'm here
to do here to win too can you crack the
top seven i'm gonna play well i'm gonna
crack the top 70.
[Music]